he left for something that was supposed
to be special right no he said he said
so he's fight supposed to fight John
Johnny Depp pulling out DC took the
fight and he said even when he's going
through cabbies like God I'm just
I've lost love for the game okay who's
in the back basically similar situation
Vito his coaches I don't feel like doing
this man like when I go out there you
guys so you see me in the fight kind of
looking for way out ended up finding a
way out was a calm down it was this with
DC yeah he's only had two losses you
know they are DC in DC so yeah DC twice
so at light heavyweight so you're tired
as number one Bob seriously contender
lost wonder what happens now how old is
he
36 but at heavyweight you fine so we'll
see heavyweight you're fine that yeah
heavier throw is older cane retired you
know that came retired he said yeah how
crazy then no one gets it like it's not
anyway
like can you Velasquez top three great
you have all time but it was not you so
long ago people's you know people I'm
moving on the province he hasn't been
active yeah so it's like you especially
this new wave of ESPN fans they don't
know who he is right you know that's got
a [ __ ] up by Francis so yeah yeah kind
of I know it's Cain Velasquez I know I
know
well the greatest ever do it there's I
get him or fate or ever do worse or
Steve but where's Weidman why every
fights this Friday he does a light
heavyweight who's da McCray is great
fight Friday in Boston TD Garden great
fight
phenomenal fight uh were you surprised
by the Cub Swanson fight no I called it
I died Todd put a thousands of dollars
on it you did yeah you call it oh yeah
terrible matchup for code I don't know
what the [ __ ] yesterday was thinking but
just because you know because was so
[ __ ] good he just he's just such an
MMA fighter look all chrome does is grab
that's who um Cub Swanson who's a black
bow why would they do that to him I
don't because they thought Cub lost his
last four so I go he's over the hill
let's give Cronin name like oh it's
still Cub Swanson he [ __ ] all comers
yeah I kept Swanson's how bad the
greatest comeback because
Kron after
when that fight in any facet it crossed
the board not even close
chrome gets the backstage because I won
that fight contact yeah guys I
definitely won that fight and they have
tweeted out I won that fight and also
the world is round my friend because
he's a flat earther you and I won the I
won the fight in the world as definitely
didn't have won that fight did he I
heard the same thing to I don't hate you
how was what was he thinking just
delusional you know like maybe he'll be
needs to watch the film you know
sometimes you think you clearly won a
fight and you look back like oh [ __ ] I
didn't you know there's certain things
oh maybe huh
I'm even thinks because he's walking
forward getting lit up like Oz degress
er I won the fight now he's getting lit
up though he's very new to my name it
laughs I wasn't close cuz when he was
bang his chest I thought you're not
saying you won here are you yeah and
they're like lifts them up like what is
happening right now
strange very very weird that's a mmm
that's yeah was that the fight question
you had though yeah it was stupid
Michelle Watterson's fight your honor
you ginger how dare you yeah
I missed that yes the main event I'm
sorry she got lit up Michelle did lit up
she had once you had a few moments where
it was she got her back but your honor
looked phenomenal
she got lint on your honest so funny
look there's Chrome I won that fight he
posted it crazy dude what crazy that's
incredible to me I love Chrome I love
girl and that I don't know that's crazy
okay
yeah in that strange man fighter fighter
you know when it's that boy it's almost
like you know it's it's like you know
playing the Patriots you lose by 40 Mike
I think that was close to the neat thing
we won that like fighters were did you
know is yeah the judge is Raymond I'm
judges sucked in the Jews like what yeah
we're awful but even we didn't have that
way right it's really interesting
there's a lot a lot of good fights
coming up man yeah but uh your boy
Widener fights Friday oh I like Whiteman
has a dog man I'm you know me when
was going to light-heavyweight I was
super high in Lucca light-heavyweight I
thought he was the answer for Jon Jones
honesty didn't work out that way
lack of itch was like holding my beer
and was suck in the [ __ ] jaw yeah and
Luke was slower they just didn't want to
be there there who calls said it I told
that he's like I'm done I he said after
he won you what I say what I tell what I
tell you between that but you said I
throw it I'm Tony Luke doesn't want to
do it anymore
yeah in people like y'all you such a
hater like I'm hung in there I was that
guy I'm telling you I see similar traits
hook's amazing father I was even closest
down cynthia's Luke and Luke you know
nobody champion the world he's a Hall of
Fame right phenom UFC Hall of Famer yeah
Strikeforce Hall of Fame yeah what the
greatest ever do it I'm telling you man
yeah I saw something I go oh no it oh no
no yeah I'm telling him it yeah
mmm just how long can you fight before
you lose but but there's you look at
certain traits and guys like you'll get
a guy who's in the thick of it like a
style bender yeah or like Darren tail
when he's you know like a yeah oh you're
Tony Ferguson you look at these guys who
are foaming tough I can't marry to get a
get in there that's what it takes yes so
when you don't see that I'm gonna be a
model over here AK you know my leg did
there's guys who can't live without this
man yes those are the guys who make it
to the top of it now Luke used to be
like that yeah and then he said it
here's the thing there's nothing wrong
with it Kane retiring fantastic yeah
found another career yes so 4ww here but
i'm so fortunate i don't what kind of
pays getting but I assume it's good cuz
I think all I think I don't want much
WWE look into three major wrestling
leagues they all offered him contracts
so I'm assuming he's getting paper Luke
and Daniel weird will tell you that that
in Cain's prime there was no one like
him like he would turn their heads
around like him came on and beat the
[ __ ] did have they told you stories
about ya know beat the [ __ ] out of
everybody yeah on ok was a I mean they
Todd Duffee was up there - during Cain's
write out the haste motto one the best
that I've seen in the gym clouds like
okhane no no
different thing right well yeah yeah
never and also had crazy cardio being
this there's the number one thing name
one guy and you have seen him go five
rounds at heavyweight right eating crazy
he decided do it see pay do it but not
like Kane where it's a tidal wave where
first round I can write second round
third round steep a applies oppression
as a similar kind of fighting style but
Cain that fourth and fifth was like a
Diaz brother you know I'm saying it's so
crazy head in your chest newsman bad
bang kit low kicks punching great boxing
is great head movement didn't get for
fights in the UFC and then was fighting
like no Garrincha Cheick Kongo Ben
Rothwell yeah just up Brock Lesnar who'd
Keller Romero I found the same card when
he fought out Brock Lesnar I fight
Gabriel Gonzaga opened up the main card
I fought Gonzaga
he fought Brock Lesnar how are those
feet why were those late waiting for ya
how are those leg kicks against Gonzaga
yeah I could have walked through the
airport is that true
uh-uh that day I was in a wheelchair
what oh yeah
really yeah where was he kicking you in
the [ __ ] just like ever he'd have hit
and would you just brace yourself you
wouldn't check him I would check him and
I'll counter and make him pay every time
that was the best I ever had like when
you check though I mean with your shin
or you just check no because he's doing
all bone so I just take it knock it in
but I'm trying to knock him out
uh-oh I'll trade you this for this yeah
yeah keep doing it I remember he's so
hairy I remember we were taking piss
tests together and I looked over at his
piss and it was brown what yeah it was
like baby's just super dehydrated that
of course he pisses Brown
it was brownish guy God he was so
[ __ ] scary oh yeah we're gonna soup
deep dive on fighting but remember
walking because Cain was fighting Brock
I remember I well that's what I want it
that's that's where I need to get yeah
and I remember I was fighting Gabriel he
was coming off his loss against JDS then
they give him to me and you still ranked
that thing in the top ten and I remember
walking out going if I don't beat him
I'm in retire really yep I told all my
team that I go if I can't if I can't be
Gabriel then I'm just you know it I'll
never be able to get to where I need to
go good guy three round decision man
yeah you haven't fallen is that you
didn't you just boxing him right yeah
non-stop okay hey click on that one
where he's down chin the far left yeah
that's one yeah don't thought it was on
that right was it does it yeah like that
one
where was this now if you a kick and I
hit him and he went down and was at the
end of the round or that was in the
fight end of the round
crazy right I don't recognize I always
think of you other reckon in those
situations is being like you just it was
almost like desperation like you were
like I gotta be a fighter I guess now
yeah yep there we go gotta just fight
out of that yeah all right I don't
recognize that guy he looks like knows
there's differences terrible my nose
took many hits yeah
terrifying just yeah but you did a lot
of like you were just throwing you would
throw in the beginning without that one
was all diced behind my jab that does
best friend but as they call it I was in
the zone I mean that's great
good good yeah I was in the zone you
know when they talk about being like the
white light you're on the zone that's
the only fight I ever had my careers in
the zone ever just not nervous just kind
of just uh it's just there that day for
a reason no much you can do like that
over the top it doesn't feel good to
block that with your hand well you know
here he is though he's fighting a void
talk about differences I will be in
Philadelphia at the Philadelphia helium
he's fighting bare-knuckle against
Bigfoot Sylvan Florida that's a tough
one is that right
that's right tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[ __ ] business